je vous le dis on a préparé une voiture
jérôme revon est-ce qu'on a la caméra
s'il vous plaît qui peut nous montrer ce
qui va se passer maintenant parce qu'on
va faire les rois du parking je vous en
sentez vous allez vous relooker dans une
voiture qui va faire des tonneaux
donc la voiture donc va tourner je veux
choisir deux qui vont devoir se relooker
pendant cette épreuve qui envie de jal
et déjà comme ça mais reprenons qui n'a
pas du tout envie d'y aller moi j'ai la
radio vous avez la radio et bien vous
allez faire alors ça veut dire à la
radio après directement gilles est ce
que voulait y aller ah oui avec plaisir
c'est vrai logique il faut revenir
relooké vous allez faire des tonneaux et
vous avez plein d'affaires dans la
voiture plein de vêtements vous essayez
de vous déshabiller de vous changer
et au bout d'une minute on arrête tout
faire une minute trente enfin on
arrêtera quand on le sentira allez c'est
parti
vous allez on va vous retrouver dans un
instant si l'on doit faire des tonneaux
dans la voiture voilà et ils vont
essayer de se changer
c'est un alésien les chéris allez-y vous
pouvez y aller vous pouvez monter
jean-michel tout cas vous êtes très beau
charmant non mais vous restez très beau
je vous le dis dans toute situation
attention va faire tourner la voiture en
fait ils ont plein d'affaires dans la
voiture répondait voir tu qui
s'habillent regarder a aussi c'est une
belle barbare j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
un jour et j'ai senti gt et perdu son
ballet dansé cpa j'ai vraiment j'étais
folle de lui mais j'ai senti qu'il
allait me faire du mal on sentit que
c'est une personnalité qu'elle aime
faire du mal donc au dernier moment j'ai
fui j'ai bien fait puisqu'il est
actuellement à fleury mérogis surtout
qu'il ya plein de gens qui regardent ça
m'est arrivé
françois viot je vous avais dit voilà
quand vous vous êtes déjà rétracter non
parce que quand je dis oui c'est pour la
vie même ça dure pas la vie voilà donc
ces professionnellement mais
sentimentalement non parce que j'avais
fait un devis donc ne savait que ça
serait bien
j'y vois j'ai fui oui ah ouais ouais bah
un peu comme l'agriculteur qui tombe pas
amoureuse trop d'amour trop désir trop
de tout je veux je veux faire naître le
vrai gilles matte elle hurlait vous a
dit ça et là c'est parti
wen a dit vous je veux faire mais
d'aller ouvrir allez salut suffisait pas
le fuji et c'est ça ma ça m'a fait peur
et on va voir celui qui sera qui aura le
plus avancé sera le plus lookée savage
envie je me sens pas bien mon chéri tout
cas vous passait très bien l'antenne et
oliva top
moi je suis dégueulasse c'est ça moi je
suis contre le fait de se rétracter les
filles en bas il se rétracte à une fois
que je suis avec valérie bah moi ça
m'arrive en fait de 2 2 me chauffer en
me disant le pauvre et où vas-y quoi ça
mais alors c'est vrai que vous alors je
vous le dis pas par des mails aïn chock
souvent par pitié alors oui nombreux
noms mais je vous le dis je le sais le
nombre de lacs qui ont pécho allez
l'aimer parce qu elle a eu pitié mais
j'en ai une liste longue comme un jour
sans pain jouer après je me dis après tu
enfin valérie seces si je suis à rien ça
l'est sap
non mais fut alors avez vous arrivez
vous êtes dépressif au pbd s'est à peine
alors je me dis le pauvre les cendres
est tombée du nid du monde si bas c'est
un peu je compte aussi donc il faut que
ce soit aussi heureuse donc avec vous
nous a fait une valve une isabelle
morini-bosc ailleurs que vous je suis
d'accord avec elle ça m'est arrivé aussi
pourquoi tu me dis je vais le prendre en
charge après il sera bien d'accord sinon
vous croyez chez sophie de la banque
tout est fait pour arrêter ces très bons
atouts en avant oui dans son bel et bien
les bobos plus tôt alors comment ça va
les gars c'est gagné pour gildas
[Applaudissements]